It's been two weeks since I've given birth,
so let's talk about my birth story.
I believe that two weeks ago,
she fit inside of me.
All started about a week and a half before I actually gave birth.
I would have contractions every night, starting around, like, 6 or 7 p m,
but they would taper off around 11 or 12.
After the first night,
I thought I was going into labor,
but I ended up not going into labor, obviously.
And then I had my midwife appointment the next day.
I was already 3 cm dilated,
so we decided to do a membrane sweep.
With my other two pregnancies,
I went into labor the same day I got the sweep.
So I was convinced that this was gonna happen again
the third time around.
That evening, I got everything prepped.
I was so convinced I was gonna give birth,
I told lucky. We called his parents,
my parents.
We were just all prepping for this baby to arrive that same night.
So then my contraction started like they did the night before,
and they grew an intensity.
They ended up being about a minute long and every five minutes apart.
So I decided to call my midwife.
Tapered off again,
and I got really discouraged
cause I was mentally prepping for her to come that night.
After a few more nights of contractions,
I got so tired
because we ended up going to bed really late every night.
That I decided to do everything I could to get this baby out.
We drank the Castor oil smoothie,
I did dry pumping,
we went on walks,
I got body work done,
went to the chiropractor,
got massages, we did acupressure,
we did everything we could to get this baby out.
Nothing worked.
And after about a week and a half of contractions every night,
I just decided to give it a rest
and let her come whenever she wanted to come.
The night I went into labor,
we decided to go on an afternoon walk with the kids.
I just got hit with this realization on that walk
that our life was gonna change so much once this baby came.
And I don't know what it was,
but all of a sudden, I started having contractions,
started becoming more frequent.
So we decided to cut our walk short and just go home.
When we got home,
I started dry pumping and just walking up and down the stairs
in between contractions.
While lucky was putting the to bed,
they started getting more intense again,
but then at 11:30,
they stopped all together.
On 1:30, we finally made it to bed,
and I was so tired.
I immediately tried to go to sleep,
and so did lucky.
About five minutes later,
when got a really strong contraction. After two hours of nothing.
So I didn't really think much of it.
I just decided to sleep through it.
But then the Next one was not even a minute later,
and it was so strong that I could not sleep through it.
And it was so painful. For the next 10 minutes,
I just had contraction after contraction.
And at this point,
lucky was waking up because I was making a lot of different sounds.
My contractions were getting so painful that I could barely move.
And I told lucky to call the midwife
cause I knew I was in active labor.
He wasn't too sure.
He was asking me whether I'm sure whether I really wanna call her,
because we'd called her the other nights when it was false labor.
But I just knew.
So we called her and they said they were about 30 minutes out.
So I was on all fours, leaning against our bed in our bedroom
when I told lucky that I felt the urge to push.
And he immediately knew what that meant.
So I was just on the floor pushing,
and he was behind me
trying to figure out whether this baby was gonna come or not,
because our midwives were still kind of far away.
After a couple pushes,
he told me that he saw the head. Because I asked him what was going on,
and he said that he saw the head and that she was coming right now.
We both knew that our midwives would not be at our house in time.
Lucky stepped up and caught her.
After a couple more Pushes placed her on my chest,
and it was the most magical experience.
After lucky placed her on my chest,
we just kind of sat there
not being able to comprehend what just happened.
And then 15 or 20 minutes later on, Midwest walked through the door.
After our midwifes arrived,
I delivered the placenta.
And then a few hours later,
we cut her cord and did all the stuff we needed to do.
And then three hours later,
our midwives left,
and we were in bed with our new baby.
And that's how little whimsy little was born.